The battle you're meant to fight is upon us
there's no one on this planet that can stopme
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
Black Adam review they're finally letting us talk
about the movie if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a lot we have to talk about a lot that just
happened with DC movies in general going forward
because of what they did in this movie and because
I'm posting this a couple days before the movie
comes out everywhere I'll try to keep this as
non-spoilery as possible but like there's a bunch
of big stuff that they set up in this movie so
it's really good news if you're a fan of DC movies
my full post credit scene video full breakdown
Easter eggs for the entire movie all that stuff
we'll start posting later this week after it does
come out in theaters so if you do have a chance
to see the movie early please don't post spoilers
on this video but the movie is basically an origin
story for The Rock's Black Adam and the DCEU all
the trailers are fairly accurate to the actual
Vibe of the movie Sometimes you get trailers that
are very misleading most of the trailers for this
movie have been pretty accurate is probably one
of the most hardcore DC movies that you'll see in
a while while since the James Gunn Suicide Squad
movie which was rated our Black Adam was rated R
for most of its life until they edited it down
to PG-13 like they just crossed the line over
PG-13 probably mostly for violence and swearing
and if there was a question this movie is inside
the dceu with all the things going on lately all
the drama behind the scenes you could even say the
movie kind of saved the dceu and that is because
of the rock so even if you're not a huge fan of
the Rocks movies just in general give credit where
credit is due he deserves all the props he gets
after this movie comes out even people who aren't
really huge fans of his will appreciate what he
did behind the scenes to make some really big DCEU
things happen behind the scenes for this overall
the plot of the movie is a pretty simple setup
it's an anti-hero movie with a rock doing his
usual thing like one of the big things with him
is that you kind of know what you're getting when
you go to see a movie with The Rock in it it is a
rock movie Inside the DCEU he has a very specific
range very specific type of character that he
plays yes there is some comedy in the movie like
they do have jokes but it's mostly coming from
other characters around Black Adam reacting to
all the crazy WTF stuff he does you've seen all
the trailers where he references being the most
powerful character on this planet like wink behind
the camera that's obviously a Superman reference
by the way like this planet because Superman is
from Krypton is why they've been releasing all
those Black Adam Justice League trailers with that
scene in it like I am the most powerful character
on this planet we know exactly what you're talking
about is basically Black Adam in character saying
that nothing on this planet can stop him including
the Justice League characters he's not afraid of
anything he thinks of himself as a God and
he thinks that he's completely Untouchable
unkillable so if you have a character like that
who just thinks they're completely Invincible most
of the problems that he experiences in the movie
are more emotional more mental problems Less Than
Physical like there are a lot of physical fights
obviously there's a big villain that he has to
face and punch the crap out of there are a few
moments where you feel like he may have found his
physical equal but he's still able to Triumph in
the movie like this is a rock movie there aren't
going to be a lot of Rock movies where he winds up
failing hardcore during the film and because they
want the character to be the de facto anti-hero of
the dceu like on the entire planet talking about
all the characters in the DCEU he could help you
one day just as much as he could also be fighting
you the next day the main villain of the movie is
meant to be someone who's even worse than him so
that he does feel like he could potentially be a
hero if he wanted to that's the bach who's a demon
from the Shazam comics like we're talking about
shared history with the Shazam character don't
worry I'll address that too because obviously this
is just about Black Adam there aren't really any
big Shazam characters in the film other than the
backstory with the wizard this about character
works pretty similarly to the way that the Shazam
and the Black Adam characters work just in terms
of their powers Shazam and Black Adam are granted
the power of different gods their names stand for
acronyms of all the gods that they get their
powers from zabak can do the same thing Grant
people his power he's like the gods that grant
them their power but in this movie he himself
is Unleashed on the world plans to conquer
it which is where the Black Adam character
comes in in Unstoppable Force meets an immovable
object you can decide which one the Black Adam
character is in that's scenario like is he the
Unstoppable force or is he the immovable object
and even though they want the sabot character to
feel like he's a threat to Black Adam so much of
the movie is him just walking over everyone else
in funny WTF ways like you see him just punting
people across the country like it's no big deal in
a way that makes him feel a little bit like that
evil Superman from the Justice League Snyder cup
like what would Superman be like if he didn't hold
back and just talking in terms of power levels the
way they established Black Adam he is meant to be
about as powerful as Superman but like I said it's
all about the attitude in his drive and what he
wants to do with that power where's the character
like Superman is meant to be like this benevolent
god-like figure trying to protect everyone on
planet Earth Black Adam is a character that really
only cares about his country conduct and himself
so like I said one of the big aspects of the movie
is dealing with the mental the emotional problems
that he has getting used to actually dealing with
other people and relying on other people like the
Justice Society the other big group that they're
introducing in the movie like Black Adam accepting
that he's not strong enough to do everything by
himself they kind of use use the Sarah Shahi's
Adrianna Tomaz character from the comics and her
son in the movie to humanize him a little and
soften him up and get him used to this concept
like it's okay to rely on other people Everyone
isn't always going to hurt you emotionally bad
things won't happen if you rely on other people
working on teams can be good in the movie they
serve as proxies for his dead wife and son and
we learn that their deaths are what made him
break bad five thousand years ago made him such a
hardcore person if you've read the comics a lot of
this is from the comics but it's not like a carbon
copy of exactly the way it happened in the comics
we got a little of his backstory during the first
shazam movie when the wizard told Billy about the
person that they wrongly chose to grant their
power to but they only give you a small piece
of the story during that the Black Adam movie is
meant to give you the rest of that context so that
it reframes a lot of those events and makes Black
Adam seem like less of a villain in that situation
with the seven deadly sins were the ones who
really orchestrated all those events pulled
his strings took advantage of Black Adam and they
were the ones that killed the other Wizards a much
younger version of The Wizard than fought and
trapped Black Adam in a magical prison for five
thousand years and originally you may have heard
that they were going to do The Rock's Black Adam
during the first shazam movie like they had other
plans for introducing him in the DCEU the plot of
the first shazam movie was originally going to
be more closely based on the new 52 version of
the Shazam origin story in Black Adam is a big
part of that the full comic book version of the
story basically swaps out some of the movie Doctor
Sivana plot from that first shazam movie for Black
Adam because the rock had so much influence
and control over the Black Adam character they
basically said that they were going to separate
the shazam and Black Adam origin stories so they
could devote more time to each one of them and
then eventually work up to a crossover between
the characters so they just deleted all the Black
Adam plot from the shazam movie and decided to do
that as a totally separate Solo movie and added
a little bit more from his Comics other comics
and new stuff like the Justice Society stuff
in the suicide squad Amanda Waller stuff so if
you've read any of the Black Adam comics any
of the Justice League comics where he crossed
over is not a one-to-one copy of those plots but
the vibe is very similar a lot of the movie is
meant to help it fit in the the continuity of the
dceu based on everything that's happened so far
I'll explain the timeline in a second too all the
Justice Society characters were fun Pierce Brosnan
probably my favorite he stole a lot of his scenes
as Dr Fate really happy to see Dr Fate inside the
dceu finally he's super powerful yes there have
been talks about doing spin-offs HBO shows for
the different Justice Society characters like
they probably will do a Justice Society movie
at some point a lot of the character scenes in
the movie do serve as jumping off points for
potential sequels or spin-offs like you get some
of Doctor Fate and hawkman's backstory but only
a little like just enough to leave stuff for like
a spin-offer sequel they hint in a lot of things
they imply a lot of things about their backstory
but never give you like the full backstory the new
Justice Society team during the movie is basically
what you see in all the trailers like Doctor Fate
and Hawkman are the remnants of an older Justice
Society team which existed in the DCEU long before
the Justice League formed before Superman
came to planet Earth something happened to
that original Justice Society team and they only
briefly touch on that there's a lot of history
for them to explore with that in future sequels
the movie does reference the Justice League
characters specifically through a lot of the
other characters in really funny ways just
like as Pop Culture icons inside the DCEU like
if we were living on a planet where the Justice
League existed they'd be like the most popular
people ever there'd be merch for Justice League
characters all over the place the brand new
characters on the team as you've seen in the
trailers are Adam Smasher and Cyclone they were
pretty decent they used them as the fresh off the
boat Fish Out of Water characters on the team like
Spider-Man trying to work with Iron Man and the
Avengers during that first Captain America civil
war movie but they do have some skills but they're
not used to working on a team in the same way just
to place the Black Adam movie in the dceu timeline
the present day of the movie is meant to take
place after the Justice League Snyder cut after
the James Gunn Suicide Squad movie but before
the events of Shazam 2 Fury of the Gods I know
there'll be all kinds of questions about how they
address the Shazam characters specifically during
the movie because of the Black Adam Shazam shared
history with the wizard they only briefly touch
on the Shazam related stuff leaving full-blown
Shazam vs Black Black Adam crossover for the
sequel movies The Rock has been pretty open about
that like oh yeah our plan is to eventually cross
all these characters over fans of the DCEU just
in general like DC movies in general will probably
be more interested in what the movie sets up like
how do they re-center the dceu like what is their
plan going forward now because very clearly they
wanted to establish the Rocks Black Adam as the
new center of power around which everything else
in the DCEU turns he keeps saying that phrase and
all the trailers like for the past couple years
The Rock has been releasing promos for the movie
saying the hierarchy of power in the dceu is
about to change once you watch the movie and you
understand what he means by that the path forward
for the dceu will be much clearer like oh this is
what they plan on doing with all these characters
now and obviously the Rock is now the center of a
lot of those plans I've talked about this in
my previous trailer videos too talking about
like what their plans are for the next Justice
League movie they do have plans for another
Justice League movie very different from what Zack
Snyder had planned for his Justice League 2. I've
also done a full breakdown of what Zack Snyder's
Justice League 2 in Justice League three were are
going to be so I'll put a link for that in the
description below and I know there's all this
Multiverse stuff that they have planned with
The Flash movie but the Black Adam movie seems
like it's going to be the guiding star of the dceu
just in terms of which movie has more influence on
the future direction of the DCEU so when I say
the rock kind of save the dceu is no joke like
there's a lot of crazy behind the scenes stuff
happening but The Rock has been powerful enough
to control the direction of his movies and get the
characters that he wants in his movies that has
basically helped them re-center their path going
forward like their whole idea is that they want
everything to be connected and there's only a few
exceptions to that like Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
movie is meant to take place in a different
universe and Matt Reeves said that he wants
his Batman movies with Robert Pattinson to take
place in a different universe but aside from that
everything is supposed to be connected crossover
so that they can build up a larger connected
Universe with bigger crossover movies and their
own version of an Avengers Secret Wars for the
dceu that's kind of like Crisis on infinite Earths
the Black Adam movie just helps set that up in a
much clearer way than I think that the Flash
movie was going to do you given all the behind
the scenes stuff that's been happening the Black
Adam post credit scene makes a lot of their path
forward a lot clearer if you do have a chance to
see the movie early please don't post spoilers for
that in this video I'll do a much bigger video
for the post credit scene later this week after
the movie actually comes out I just did a trailer
video last week which basically explains what's
going on so you can also watch that too I'll add a
link for that at the end of this video you've also
probably seen the past couple days the news about
Warner Brothers officially developing Man of Steel
2 you can thank the rock for being the one to make
that happen so like I said even if you're not like
the biggest fan ever of the rock if you're just
a core DC fan you at least appreciate what they
do with the dceu in this movie and like I said
overall it's a very rock type of movie you know
what you're getting when you go into it the
trailer is all pretty accurate to the vibe
of the movie and on a technical level it's just
like a very competent action adventure flick it's
a fun watch but like I said if you've seen any
of the Rock's other movies imagine one of those
inside the dceu there'll be a thousand questions
about everything after the movie comes out so
post your questions in the comments below and
I'll try to address those during my full Easter
egg breakdown videos later this week everyone
click here for that new Black Adam Justice League
video that I just mentioned and click here for
my house of the dragon episode 10 finale video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!